[Music]
Newsweek magazine which has been around
since 1933 it's an icon among American
magazines will no longer be available in
print after December 31st of this year
now there's still going to be an online
version of Newsweek
but this magazine that I grew up with
you know what we all grew up seeing it
as the newsstand anymore it's gonna be
gone it's kind of it's it's sad you know
it's sad it's a little mind-boggling and
what's even stranger and sadder is when
you see some of the magazines that
actually outlasted Newsweek news weeks
gone right but these magazines still
exist these are all completely real we
didn't make these up ladies and
gentleman amateur radio still still
thriving what you know what you know
what they say sex sells look at this
news week's gone but not airports of the
world featuring Dusseldorf look at this
just labs magazine that puppy just heard
that Newsweek went out of business
I don't like time or where to retire
magazine apparently you know where
you're supposed to retire Andy the we we
just slid back here in these weeds and
no one bothers us
okay news weeks gone but not chest life
yeah this is real look at this guy from
the cover living like a rock star
it's the unhappiest man I've never seen
anything better
he's so pissed off this is again these
are all real witches and pagans magazine
oh dear still thriving though Newsweek
God
there she is here's one I couldn't have
made this up if I wanted to racing
pigeon pictorial oh is that hair that is
hairy
yeah yes Andy you could tell by his
coloration check this out pond hopping
oh yeah
featuring an article get in there on
perch gherkin exterior and some party
you ever do any perched Turk and Andy is
doing some right yeah
magazines exist forget your Newsweek
look at this real magazine called poll
Spin Magazine I thought that just all
just poll artistry Anastos also that's
really the it was not really the most
erotic pose between two people I don't
know I don't think so but I'm in there
Hey look at this
laughs with that strong fine TV here we
go
look at magazines still exist even
though Newsweek is gone we'd world yeah
celebrating celebrating its 100th issue
they think yeah sure seems like a
hundred Chad this look at this magazine
right here
American ginger
and finally porn aficionado
[Applause]
that doesn't contain for just people who
like porn it's all yeah yeah it's all
you I got it
state to reading from the grandparents
it's a hundred pictures of Andy going
like that
[Laughter]